hello and welcome to the new world
review source for everything anime and
manga and today we are here to discover
the answer to a grand hypothetical being
could the phantom troop defeat meroem's
royal guard
note not meruem himself just the royal
guard and i find this to be a
particularly fascinating question
because the immediate knee-jerk reaction
to that sort of inquiry
would generally be nope absolutely not
the troop will get crushed like bugs
by bugs whereas after having thought
about it i think it might actually be
the other way around
diving into the troop actually reveals
some pretty terrifying possibilities the
most terrifying of which is obviously
the prospect of subscribing to the new
world review which will have the side
effect of granting you regular hunt on
content uploaded straight into your
youtube feed i know it's a scary thing
but we all need to overcome our fears
right here and now by pushing this
button let me know how you do in the
comments below but before getting into
this i should probably define which
phantom troop i'm talking about by which
i mean the exact composition of the crew
because it has changed over time and our
band in the succession wall arc looked
quite different to our york new city
group for the sake of putting them up
against the royal guard i'm going to be
using the phantom troupe during the
chimera antarctic so that we have a
roughly time appropriate comparison and
to recap who we have on hand well that
would be feitan think shizuku ban olonov
kalato no banaga cortopi sharnak
franklin
and chrollo yes krollo canonically he
actually got his nan back during the
chimera antarctic because you can see
hisoka and arbingana approaching him
on the cover of chapter 201 where crollo
also appears to be reading a copy of
weekly shonen jump which is a very fun
nod but as a result yes our leader can
participate
meanwhile for our royal guard we of
course have our well-known and
well-loved nephipito and mentholupi as
well as the almost universally despised
shah proof and i would like to start by
analyzing the skill set of the royal
guard because what became very apparent
to me whilst looking at this topic is
that they really don't have particularly
useful combative abilities and those
that do exist are quite shockingly basic
so for example pito developed their
heart so pretty much in an effort just
to entertain themselves dr blyth is a
healing ability that effuse leaves pito
extraordinarily vulnerable and
practically unable to protect themselves
meanwhile puppeteering could be a useful
manipulation power except it requires
the target to have been operated on with
dr blyth and that is going to be
quite a rough condition to fulfill
alpito really has to their name as to
obscore which merely enhances pito's
physical prowess beyond natural limits
as for shayapuf he does have a few
useful tricky things like beelzebub
which will make annihilating him quite
difficult but his spiritual message
hatsu was developed for the purpose of
basically corralling cattle for the king
and his cocoon power which grants
non-abilities to others is going to be
useless because it takes at least 24
hours to take effect hoof can also
change his body to mimic others so that
might
be useful but in the end he is also
pretty much just left in a physical
standoff as is yupi who has no abilities
whatsoever outside of bodily enhancement
manipulation and
general ragey ragi blasty goodness and
with all of this in mind the royal guard
just don't have a particularly strong
win condition for them they simply need
to rip their opponents to pieces with
their bare hands or with their cat hands
i suppose and that
is going to be problematic against this
particular group of people because the
phantom troop are the exact opposite
really they are a group of highly
skilled and efficient end users who have
developed abilities for the very key
purpose of survival and together those
abilities complement and enhance every
other member of the troop furthermore
they also have one of the greatest
geniuses in hunter hunter to instruct
them on exactly how to implement said
powers because crawler really is the key
to everything not so much because of his
abilities but because he is the only
person in this world capable of making
the troop work together as a cohesive
unit
and also he is without a doubt more
intelligent than anyone of the royal
guard he will dissect them with ease and
implement a strategy to deal with them
of which there are many options because
the troop have a wide array of win
conditions as
opposed to the singular condition of the
royal guard and the first of which comes
in the form of thinx he is an often
overlooked character in favour of crollo
or feitan but under these conditions his
nen ability is devastating in case you
need a refresher it's called the ripper
cyclotron whereby his aura increases
with every rotation of his arm allowing
him to punch an opponent at well
i suppose pretty much any force in
theory there is no limit to thinks his
ability he could just keep rotating on
and on and on into eternity potentially
reaching the point where he could even
one punch man meroem out of existence
the trade-off is of course the time it
takes to prepare his attacks which to
dispatch of a royal guard will be
a pretty incredible amount of rotations
i mean to beat a basic men using chimera
and finks used 15 rotations although he
did go on to say that less than half of
that would have been necessary so if he
got that number up into the hundreds
perhaps even thousands
we are undoubtedly looking at a pretty
dead royal guard on impact
and a prime target for this would be
pitot because they are surprisingly
fragile you'd be as much more of a tank
so using ripple cyclotron on him could
be a bit of a risk and pouf can survive
by splitting into smaller bodies so
peter would be the correct target but it
would still be a pretty devastating
attack if used on any one of them and
thinks would be allowed to charge this
up because the phantom troop have the
incredible advantage of numbers and
endless ways that they could stall kite
and distract the royal guard and if one
of them does get injured in the process
well there's always machi to just string
them back
up then it would be all about creating
an opportunity for things to strike but
the best part is that after the initial
ripper cyclotron the remaining guards
would of course be wary of things at
which point crawler could just take his
ability and while the guard's aware of
things crawler could just quietly charge
up a second round of ripper cyclotron in
the background because it really is one
of the more absurd abilities in the
series and it's also not the only win
condition that phantom troop have in
fact it's not even the easiest condition
to meet and here we now turn to crawler
himself who has an ability called fun
fun cloth which he stole from al one of
the
the shadow beast and as far as we know
al is still alive and crolo still has
the fun fun cloth in his book and just
quickly because crowler gets
well he gets complicated in combat the
abilities he has access to in this
hypothetical are restricted to the ones
we've seen up until the chimera
antarctic or ones that he can borrow
from fellow troop members
and this is relevant because in the
manga he now has this whole slew of
hatsu which we will just temporarily
forget about for the sake of this video
doesn't matter anyway though because fun
fun cloth is capable of shrinking anyone
who ends up in it and effectively traps
them until the user decides to uncover
them it's almost like being stuck in a
pocket dimension and if it were to take
effect then that does take one whole
royal guard out of the fight and it
would probably be best used on either
pito or up
shayapov is a problem once again because
even if he does get shrunk he can
potentially escape the cloth through the
bl's above ability in the same manner by
which he slipped through moral smoky
jail he's a very
very slippery butterfly boof is by far
the biggest problem to the troop but
only in that it's very difficult to kill
him not so much that he's particularly
threatening in any way meanwhile yupi
can be easily outsmarted and pito
operates on sheer natural instinct
neither of which are phenomenal options
against the entirety of the phantom
troop so what's another way to
potentially deal with the royal guard
well we also have a fairly obvious
option with shaonax black voice
there's something quite beautiful about
pure manipulation which is that once the
conditions have been fulfilled
that's kind of that if somehow the troop
are able to equip a royal guard with one
of charnock's two antennae then they're
just plain done the only one who has any
defense against it whatsoever is
neferpitou because if peter was using
terp's core at the time which
manipulates them then charnock's
antennae would be unable to take control
due to the whole manipulator first come
first serve rule so for targets we would
be looking at either yupi or pouf poof
might be a problem yet again because
let's say he splits himself when we take
control of one of his bodies it's kind
of unclear what would happen to the
other separate proofs these are the one
hit ko victories though landing a fully
charged ripper cyclotron capturing a
guard in the fun funk cloth or taking
control of them with black voice all of
which are pretty fantastic options but
that doesn't mean we're out of choices
though one fun combination to think
about is actually shizuku and kalato
because kalato has a hanzo known as
dance of the serpent's bite which rains
down seemingly harmless confetti upon an
opponent
completely harmless until one piece of
paper gets stuck after which point color
toe is capable of dealing pretty severe
damage even to nen wielding chimera ants
but the real beauty of this is that
kalato doesn't need to deal the
finishing blow at all what we really
need are just a couple of wounds after
which point shizuku could invoke blinky
to drain the royal guard of all their
blood which does of course only work if
we can keep shizuku safe color toe as
well for that matter but it is a
potentially devastating combination and
in terms of dealing sheer damage i will
mention feitan's pain packer but i also
think that this is one of the more risky
ideas it basically
allows him to transmute pain inflicted
upon him in battle into well or of his
choosing the only example of which we
have was the scorching heat of the
rising sun hansu and this
could work the problem is that it
involves feitan actively taking damage
which is very risky
because if a royal guard does manage to
strike feitan or any member of the troop
really then that could result in an
instant death physically the royal guard
are all extraordinarily dangerous and
close combat should really be avoided
unless the troop have any one of the
three one hit wing conditions ready to
go although one way the troop may be
able to use the paint packer is if they
damage feitan rather than the royal
guard but it's still a very risky idea
because the damage radius could decimate
the other troop members as well
for incredible damage i would say
bernoullinov is a potentially better
option
because he can conjure this miniature
jupiter that strikes opponents at the
speed of sound and is completely
inescapable so long as the target is
within earshot of bernoullinov's
beautiful music with that said i'm
unsure if jupiter would be
powerful enough to actually take out a
royal guard which is ridiculous because
it's one of like the strongest attacks
we've ever seen in hunter hunter but i
would not be surprised to see any one of
the three managing to survive it
benolinov also has a very
maybe useful ability called cantabile
metamorphism where he can allegedly
transform into quote different things
perhaps even mimic the bodies of others
which could be useful as a distraction
like if say he was able to transform
into thinks and act as a decoy or
something that's extremely speculative
though and i've tried to avoid that kind
of talk thus far because
here's the thing we still know very very
little about the full capabilities of
the phantom troop i mean there are
members we haven't even spoken about
here at all like nobunaga for example
whose non-abilities are still completely
unknown we don't know the full extent of
franklin either or feitan for that
matter because it's heavily implied that
he has other forms of the paint packer
suit that each have different fuel
requirements for various different
outcomes
so we're really only scratching the
surface with this group and we still
have
all of these possibilities to deal with
the royal guard meanwhile when it comes
to the ants we are aware of their full
capabilities and apart from their
physical prowess i have to say
it isn't all that impressive for the
most part their abilities were created
to either entertain themselves or to
serve a greater purpose for the king
they're not designed with a particular
efficiency in mind
and certainly not for pure combat and
survival which is why for example pito
has such an awkward and costly healing
mechanism with dr blyth whereas machi of
the troop has a very potent and
time-efficient healing ability
so not only do the phantom troop have
access to a much much broader pool of
powers
they're also just significantly more
optimized for the task at hand
and even if a couple of the troop
members were to fall to the overwhelming
power of the royal guard
there's still so many of them remaining
and as long as crawler stays alive he
will be able to formulate a winning
strategy which is another thing to point
out i suppose the royal
guard do not work very well together
they each have entirely different
fighting styles and varying personal
motivations and worst of all the curse
of youth and inexperience
they've only been in this world for a
couple of months and that becomes very
obvious in regards to the various
mistakes they make and character arcs
they need to embark on meanwhile the
phantom troop are a legion of grizzled
veterans
they're not as strong as the royal guard
but they're far more experienced and
much more well equipped to take on any
challenge that comes their way
so long as that challenge is not the end
king mirowam however when it comes to
the phantom troop versus the royal guard
i quite firmly believe that the troop
would comfortably take this but what do
you guys think please do leave your
thoughts in the comments below or even
join my discord server and if you gain
for some more hunt onto content then
please do go and check out some of my
other videos or even subscribe to the
channel
for regular hunter hunter glory
delivered straight into your youtube
feed but for now this has been the new
world review and i'll see you next time